be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while I play video
games and talk to you about random life
stuff
what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to another episode of the
rundown where I give you guys a no
frills explanation on characters and
teams and concepts from comic book
movies and TV shows and so on and so
forth anyway first things first this
video is gonna have spoilers as if you
needed to be told that but some people
need to be told the obvious whatever
anyway so I just finished watching x-men
apocalypse and I think one of the
biggest questions people are gonna have
is what was the post-credits scene about
what is Essex Corp well for those of us
who have been big fans of the x-men for
a pretty decent amount of time we knew
that when apocalypse was announced to be
the main villain of the x-men movie most
likely somewhere along the line Essex
Corp was gonna come into the equation so
the question becomes this what's Essex
Court well Essex Corp is the front for a
man named Nathaniel Essex also known as
mr. sinister now why does this matter
because in Marvel Comics mr. sinister
had his hand in three major events the
first was his involvement with
apocalypse
the second was his involvement in the
lives of Jean Grey and Scott Summers and
the third for those of you guys who saw
the post-credits scene in Deadpool is
cable now a little bit of backstory here
we know that apocalypse has been around
for thousands and thousands of years and
so on I've got a big video explaining
his whole backstory if you want to check
that out and I've got a video on the
four horsemen a video on his powers and
anything you want to know about
apocalypse can be covered on this
channel and you'll find all those links
down in the description but during
apocalypses lifespan he had basically
travel the world with conquering
civilizations different things like that
well during this time he came across a
guy named Nathaniel Essex in the 1800's
in England and Nathaniel Essex was like
the Charles Xavier before Charles Xavier
in the sense that he was like somewhere
along the line there's going to be this
massive surge in mutant population
mutants are just gonna start popping out
all over the place
there's been a few here and there but
they're mostly conjecture and rumor
nobody really believes they exist but
you know there's going to be a huge
influx of them well the scientific
community was like you're crazy
Nathaniel Essex get out of here go do
your own weird whatever it is that you
do well Essex had actually been
kidnapping those that he believed were
mutants and experimenting on him trying
to discover why it was
mutants trying to figure out where their
powers came from well during this time
he runs into apocalypse and apocalypse
is surprised by what he learns because
apocalypse did not know that he was a
mutant instead he just thought he was
the only person in the world that could
do the kind of stuff that he could do
but once he learned he was mutants
that's where his ideology came that he
should be a leader of the world to even
population he should be their Messiah
and that kind of crazy thinking that
makes his story so awesome but
nonetheless so he goes to sinister and
it says I will bestow upon you the gift
of eternal life so you can spend the
rest of your life studying mutant genome
and all that kind of good stuff
where's more that goes into it and I've
got a video on mr. sinister explained
which will be in the description as well
if you want to check that out jumping
forward a hundred years sinister always
operated in the background like no one
ever really knew who he was they just
knew there was a guy named Nathaniel
Essex and sinister was a total mystery
to the world at large as an example
during world war ii he was operating
with the nazis but they only knew him as
Nathaniel Essex and he maybe even had an
alternate name during that time period
but nonetheless he operated in the
Auschwitz concentration camp and so when
Captain America and Namor the Submariner
and Bucky Barnes in the original Human
Torch Jim Hammond when they showed up
and a-three the Auschwitz concentration
camp sinister bailed out
well the issue here was that he recorded
all of his findings in this little
journal he was literally just called
Sinister's journal well this journal was
discovered in like the 1980s I think or
something like that by a scientist who
would later use those findings to go on
and found the Weapon X project which of
course gave us Wolverine it gave us
Deadpool and all that kind of good stuff
now in terms of Jean Grey and Scott
Summers because as Sinister's
experienced with messing around and
examining the human genome and mutant
physiology and all that kind of good
stuff he had come to the conclusion that
somewhere along the line two mutants
would be born and they would produce a
child that would just be stupid ly
powerful I mean just powerful
point where you'd be godlike in terms of
its abilities well he eventually
discovered this would be Jean Grey and
Scott Summers the problem was this the
Phoenix socket happened for those of you
guys who don't know the Phoenix saga was
a point where by Jean Grey was believed
to be the Phoenix force that she had all
these crazy powers and eventually it was
all read conned and all that kind of
good stuff I've got a video on that as
well but nonetheless during the original
Phoenix saga the way the story ended
Jean Grey seemed to have sacrificed her
life in order to save the universes so
everybody thought she was dead Cyclops
thought she was dead and the x-men
thought she was dead and everybody
thought that she was gone and sinister
was sitting around like well that sucks
I mean I got to find a way to produce a
kid with Jean Grey and Scott Summers so
I can use that kid to kill apocalypse
because sinister just hated apocalypse
and so what he does is he creates a
clone named Madeline prior now when he
first made Madeline prior it was
believed that she was incapable of doing
anything and in fact sinister was
actually right with this belief the
difference was that when Jean Grey
sacrificed her life the Phoenix force
sparked a bit of life inside of Madeline
prior and brought her to life why I did
that
I don't know comics anyway so Madeline
prior sparks to life if she's got all
the powers of gene grateful epithelia
telekinesis everything except the
Phoenix force and so sinister says
harken alas I can use Madeline prior to
produce a child between Scott Summers
and Madeline and I can make this child
super-strong and so he says Madeline
prior go out into the world and find
Scott Summers and then produce a child
with him and Madeline says okay
and so she eventually finds Scott
Summers and they produce a kid named
Nathan summers well during this time
apocalypse had woken up and apocalypse
was like I see what Sinister's trying to
do here he's trying to make a kid that
can kill me well I'm gonna beat him to
the punch and I'm gonna kidnap that kid
and I'm gonna use him as a host for what
I need to transfer my essence again and
so apocalypse kidnaps Nathan summers and
then this leads to this great big huge
conflict between Cyclops and the and
x-factor and x-force
and the Inhumans and justice matters
like the world against apocalypse and of
course he able was able to hold them off
although he's eventually defeated and
the story ends up leading to Nathan
being taken into the future where he
becomes the character table but
nonetheless I digress the fact remains
that sinister is this really cool
who always operates behind the scenes
he's been watching Jean Grey and Scott
Summers virtually their entire lives and
manipulating the two of them into
eventually getting together it's uh he's
a really really cool villain he can
shape-shift he has a healing factor he
can control different kinds of energy he
has telepathy telekinesis your standard
run-of-the-mill powers for like your
villains who were really cool on the
x-men universe but anyway if you want to
know more about him check out my video
on mr. sinister explained and I won't
catch you guys on it please